la mie câline basket go c'est le plus
grand tournoi de basket du quinze de
france ce week-end plus de 29 équipes se
sont retrouvées à mantes la jolie pour
s'affronter entre elles lors des
qualifications ile de france le but
c'est de faire jouer les jeunes
le la mie câline basket c'est un tournoi
national où tous les clubs peuvent
s'inscrire parmi les clubs les yvelinois
présent l'as mantaise maurepas ou encore
maul qui l'a emporté lors du derby
contre epône 22 à 3 on a bien joué on a
réussi à les battre mais très bonne
équipe en face
on a bien défendu et c'est bon ça qu'on
avait nous on sait tout jouer et puis
ces ongs à nous parents on peut faire un
autre match et ça je trouve ça vraiment
bien parce que ça à évaluer notre niveau
une compétition organisée par l'
hypothèse pour la quatrième année
consécutive tournoi la mie câline basket
on a le niveau département régional et
national
donc ça une finale après en vendée pour
toutes les catégories ok tous les
niveaux et trois niveaux garçons et
filles donc là on a deux équipes
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont se qualifier aux
garçons et en filles au niveau
départemental et hier on a eu une équipe
qui s'est qualifiée en masculin
régionales côté garçons lui as
alfortville le levallois sporting club
se sont qualifiés pour les phases
finales qui auront lieu les 4 et 5 juin
prochains à saint jean de monts en
vendée chez les filles les sarthoises du
sable et baskets et le club hôte la
synthèse participeront également au
prochain tour